sher Disney we have time for your
meandering 30-second logo during this
nearly three hour film will wait all
these hanging with them step forward
willingly towards the news in unison and
without any product as though they've
read the script and wish to save
themselves the trouble of seeing the
rest of this mess hangman allow this
asshole kid to keep seeing instead of
hanging immediately forcing it or at
least kicking him in the balls or
something to shut him up Wow movie goes
full lame is before the 4-minute mark
they've started to sing Becket needs to
be told that the prisoners are singing
even though that's readily apparent via
here it will be dupes you into thinking
of the singing is over but continues the
same song unabated after the opening
title dangerous song to be singing for
any who are ignorant of us Meany
particularly a woman that's sexually
racist what makes you think she's alone
well the fact that up until you've spoke
she was alone and stuff also nadie
Barbosa heard that but I'm wondering if
he was expecting Elizabeth to arrive
here why did he wait until she was in
danger to show up wherever this gun was
hidden it simply means will Turner has
his work cut out for him when it comes
to marital relations not hilarious third
movie of a bloated not hilarious
franchise finds time for the scenes
somehow he please that's racist sexist
and coincidentally exactly what I was
hoping he'd say which makes me racist
sexist also I bet you didn't make
Captain Barbossa do that oh man they
drank Chalian fat into this didn't they
has this asshole been underwater this
entire time just for a cinematic reveal
why is he not dead also why did they try
to get will to steal the navigational
charts if they could simply walk in and
ask for them I mean Barbosa even has a
magic you must honor this court and they
bothered with will trying to steal this
stuff on his own as
nine pirate Lords you must honor the
call
pirates have Lords I thought it was a
pretty straightforward casual version of
a military with a captain and a first
mate pirate code yes I buy that pirate
Lords in some kind of Constitution that
they have to obey not so much yet this
movie is having one of the so-called
good guys get a chuckle out of looking
up Elizabeth skirt because creeping and
P being is fun much-needed exposition
and the pervy up skirt gag was all for
the payoff of this guy having to look at
sumo balls hilarious
Elizabeth's war there was more to you
than meets the eyes
no that's Optimus Prime you're thinking
of what is it you seek David Walker Jack
Sparrow he's one of the pirate Lords
well isn't that convenient and
completely made up for this movie Jack
Sparrow holds one of the nine pieces of
eight nine pieces of eight sounds just
odd enough as a phrase that I have to
wonder why the original pirate Lords
didn't make the council eight members
for the sake of consistency so now when
they hatched this plan they knew the
spaces between the floorboards will
allow for a coordinated sword tossing I
mean think about the planning here how
many times did Barbosa go into this room
finally deciding you know what swords
through the floorboards it's almost too
easy how did this many British soldiers
manage to get to the other side of a
pink dressing chamber dividers without
any guards spotting them swords versus
gun battle it's a lot more even than it
has any right to be
dickhead British soldiers decide to
waste time getting into position in
order to shoot the Pirates so they
somehow know exactly where the British
soldiers were standing in that moment of
chaotic battle and didn't get any good
guys with this trick as well this little
guy firing this huge gun is worthless
both for military strategy and comedic
value a whole lotta who gives a focus
you know what even if historically
soldiers did this in every situation I'm
going to sin history
here's another instance of some booby
trap exploding exactly when the soldiers
were in a spot no one could possibly
predict they'd be in that you two grand
into the same secluded area away from
the battle that Beckett's main man
Mercer just happens to be in right now
so he can overhear key information he
needs to propel flop a monkey and a
parrot team up to validate this movie's
three hour runtime pirate will help I'm
sure there must be a good reason to try
a free character speaks for the viewing
audience why don't that obey woman just
bring Jack back the same way she brought
Barbosa
as if our boss cell was only dead your
right to you how stupid it is for them
to think just because you did one
impossible thing you could do a
completely other impossible thing first
thing can bring penance it it might make
me sexist or a racist but I do not care
about one word coming out of this
woman's mouth some signals when a soul
comes back to this world from the dead
so a green flash means someone's come
back into this world from the dead
question though did those people also
have an entire ship full of people
looking for them complete with these
rare navigational charts to help him get
out or did they get out on good behavior
also listen listening the supernatural
bullshit was not what people enjoyed
about the first pirates movie it was the
zany swashbuckling thunk so tripling
down on the supernatural bull was a dumb
idea Pirates of the Caribbean the day
after tomorrow oh yeah I keep forgetting
one of this franchises characters has an
undead barnacle father who sails on a
ship with a squid captain two plays the
organ also he's technically playing that
organ with his face I'm just saying
these assholes haven't been fired yet
why is this movie three hours long
because the director insisted on every
single establishing shot being a
10-second orgy of nothingness how long
do they continue not talking you mean
they're still giving each other the
silent treatment after he saw her
kissing Jack in the last movie you mean
she hasn't once explained herself I
guess when you detention for a movie
those things happen
for what why just when will is about to
run until Barbeau so the ships in danger
tia shows up out of nowhere to give him
some sort of vague platitude then he
runs to tell Barbarossa what he was
gonna tell him before but why is the
movie interrupted even a little bit for
Tia to say this thing that could be said
at any time it's actually confusing
because it seems like will is running
because of what she says not because of
what he saw out in the water what do you
want most here's the cost most appeared
in the end super in your face
foreshadowing is super in your face for
certain you have to be lost to find the
places can't be found sure sure I get it
but you could also just be lost in a
place that's nowhere near where you need
to be
besides how in the world do people who
came through here before not map this
place out
also seems like the people who
successfully navigated the Davy Jones
locker expedition would have made
mention of a fucking waterfall 19
seconds of black screen they told Johnny
Depp he was still in Fear and Loathing
in Las Vegas this was the result it's
pretty obvious the thought was you know
what's better than Jack Sparrow
dude Jack Sparrow's and why should we
stop there Jack Sparrow lays an egg why
are you people laughing at this comic
goal almost seven full minutes of
nonsensical Jack Sparrow afterlife
bullshit that means absolutely nothing
to anything we have lost speed and
therefore time precious time cannot be
recovered once lost this advice went
unheeded by the movie itself it's pretty
obvious the thought was you know what's
better than one rock that's actually a
grab two rocks that are actually grabs
and why should we stop there
this foodie is a godforsaken place you
mean the beach yeah it looks awful wait
jack is closer than you do well that was
easy
also how do you sail the boat to Davy
Jones locker and run right into Jack is
he the only person in this purgatory how
are they're not running into millions of
people right now really you just took a
book to purgatory and you're still
hanging on to that impossible Laura
we've tried to kill me in the past one
of you succeeded Oh
she's not told ya for some reason even
though it's been months maybe even a
year since it happened what are you
doing what are you doing no what are you
doing what are you doing this is that
could've been resolved long ago skip
holy I skip to this Barton it's still
unresolved why was Jack allowed to
wander around the beach while these
people were relegated to the water like
they're in the Dead Marshes
and every 10 years in could come ashore
to be which she loved him I'm talking
about myself but much like obi-wan
Kenobi I don't see Darth Vader as Anakin
Skywalker and I sure don't see me as
myself okay sending this for her dead
father being one of the six dead person
row boats close enough to the pearl to
make out faces that's a deadly
coincidence okay Tia just said that
those dead people only see them as
ghosts so why is he reacting right now
is it so she and we would feel a lot
better about his death I learned that if
you stab the heart yours must take its
place
Wow this dead guy just dropped a
fantastic plot point on the main
character says he's being carried into
the unknown just imagine if they didn't
see him in that sea of dead people and
toys destiny
voodoo chick says this immediately after
Elizabeth's dad states that the Dutchman
must have a captain further underscoring
the obvious earlier foreshadowing you
obviously didn't take to heart no whoa
wise old with the wrong dog classic
Pirates of the Caribbean
hands on hips shaking my head far
outside Davy Jones locker jack hears and
sees literal tiny Jack angel demons
offering conflicting advice what the
fuck the Dutchman must have a captain
whatever the movie is stuck you can rest
assured it will find a way to waste time
come Sun says it won't matter
Oh Sun said hallucination ex machina of
sunset sundown is there a difference
between the two here let me suck on your
fake eye before you put it back in I
don't need to ask questions seems like a
great idea also all the people who have
ever escaped Davy Jones locker did this
that doesn't seem possible what of a
smaller crew who came to save someone
and couldn't rock the boat I guess
they're screwed how are they supposed to
know that though also when this works
will someone write all this down so
that'll be easier for others to escape
it seems like the right thing to do they
won't because after this movie no one we
care about will ever go to the djl also
while I'm at it who first learned at
dudas because someone solved it
completely on their own
I got their crew to rock the boat
willingly on the off chance it would
work and then they were assholes and
simply left a riddle instead of
full-blown instructions telescope
measuring contest there's never a
guarantee of coming back unless Tia
Dalma brings you back from the dead
because she knows magic yeah but today
somehow have dry gunpowder earlier
everyone was trying to shoot each other
and couldn't because the powder was wet
that would presumably include all these
pirates from Singapore right am I
missing something
I need the PO to free my father
seriously from the time the Black Pearl
was built until now nobody built a ship
that rivaled its speed the whole reason
will betrays jack is because he needs
this one ship for real and if Davy Jones
were to learn of your survival how does
he not know this already shouldn't some
disturbance in the force alert in the
locker escapes where I in a devoted Tory
mood what then might had to vote the
scene is an excellent example of why
this movie sucks balls instead of a
short deal-making scene this
conversation is dragged out
unnecessarily into a 10-minute snooze
fest I actually heard there's no footage
from this movie on the cutting room
floor they used everything they shot so
yeah who could it be since we've seen
Tia Dalma twice looked down at a locket
and talked about pain and losses by the
way during the last movie when she was
telling everyone the story of Davy Jones
why did she look so happy telling it I
mean they shot these movies at the same
time so it wasn't like they forgot and
just made it up for this movie or did
they cut out the middleman as it were
whose scene is still going on with me
killed you'd arrive at the cove find
it's a stronghold nigh impregnable and
then you'd be wishing oh if only there
was someone I had not killed inside this
somehow works despite the power of the
military Beckett has at his fingertips
besides why can't he just get to
shipwreck Cove before the Brethren court
gets there and why does Beckett trust
anything Jack says it's in this
pestilent traitorous cow hot and yeasty
codpiece Jack Sparrow lover of all
things scoundrel and pirate is so mad at
will for having ulterior motives for
rescuing him he undoes years of
friendship
despite having himself double-crossed
will an I uncountable number of times
prior to this
it's rape dr. Mann ex machina with all
nine pieces of aid will be free with no
evidence whatsoever South in believes
Elizabeth is Calypso and gets her an
item and crucial information for the
plot and her ex-boyfriend who is still
in love with her is on the Dutchmen
right now so he saves her and what a
bunch of lucky breaks it did no no no
what which side you choose I'm already
annoyed that this asshole is still in
these movies long after his storyline
should have ended but giving him a
change of heart now a good guy arc is
even worse this guy's original
motivation in these films was how bad he
wanted to marry Elizabeth and sex her
and not in a romantic kind of way but
suddenly he's got hurt gay I guess oh he
just happened to be in the very cell
that you are that was easy
will is killing dudes just so he can
drop them into the ocean and the birds
will leave a trail for Beckett to follow
what's lost in all this is that will is
killing people just to leave trails this
cold-blooded motherfucker is a hero a
destinies of than entwined Elizabeth but
never joined is this a pity kiss she
just sort of allows this doesn't she
Elizabeth freaks the hell out over the
death of a guy she just told could never
earn her forgiveness shocked
maybe upset sure but she's acting like
they were active lovers like this is
will or something
screw the Moody for trying to slap
together a hero's death for this
dickface Norrington I admit that's
pretty damn funny oh not a sin off why
not
don't you forget by yet to bring me back
there are way too many deals to keep up
with in this movie and almost all of
them end up in some sort of
double-crossing so who cares what deal
is in place with him I showed them how
to bind her it was an easy process I
just showed them some YouTube videos she
pretended to love me what am I doing
with my life she that tried a man the
tea drinking in this scene is a good
substitute for eating apples so the
director said take a drink of tea every
time you say something to piss Davy
Jones off it'll make you look like even
more of an asshole
that is only one
price I wanna exhibit Calypso mock-up
why didn't you just do that in the first
place instead you went through the whole
binder into human form punishment which
is like total bull man
Pirates of the Caribbean the desolation
of smaug master Agassi if you win what
possessed Barbosa to one day long ago
give his one-eyed sailor the wooden eye
that is so important to this movie's
plot what if he got thrown overboard or
burned in one of those Twilight fires
he encrusted something very important to
this dude instead of just giving him an
eyepatch this is some bull concocted by
the writers to turn a silly part of the
franchise into something way more
important than it should be
Lamas content as a cucumber to wait
until southing joins us so Fang is dead
I'm pretty sure you didn't hear that but
what wonderful timing to just be able to
walk in a room and be able to answer
that very question at this exact moment
you weren't then why the last two movies
plots almost entirely rely on young
lovers having some sort of
misunderstanding and never asking one
simple question that could have fixed it
all instead of simply asking this
question in the first place he decided
to get pirate Lords to bind her to a
human body if you can do this how did
the other thing happen by the way how
did nine pirate dudes capture a goddess
in the first place did they put out
Reese's Pieces and have her follow them
into a trap I bet they put out Reese's
Pieces and had her following them into a
trap
so Johnny Depp says he patterned his
Jack Sparrow in some way out of Keith
Richards so here he is despite taking
some of the mystique out of Depp's
performance by actually casting the guy
who inspired it like a magician
revealing a secret also where's the
other part of the equation Pepe LePew
also am I really being asked to care
about Jack Sparrow's daddy issues in the
third fucking movie cuz I don't I can't
and I won't haha because he's a famous
guitar player keeping to the code
they've been here for 12 minutes of this
movie and we still have another hour
left also this whole voting thing brings
up another horrible aspect of TV shows
and movies that start explaining it's
mythology way too far to the point that
basically lawless characters have rules
and kings and queens and all sorts of
stupid that doesn't make any sense
it's like Twilight in True Blood when
you find out vampires follow some sort
of hierarchy what a bunch of bull this
guy that's mama
I mean see do we need Jack Sparrow to be
explained in this way this comes off
totally cheap this is the midi-chlorians
of Pirates of the Caribbean as if this
movie needed any more length when it's
time to negotiate the parties to
to land on opposite sides of a Long
Island in which the entire walk towards
each other will be shown for our
amusement sure throw in the compass this
can't possibly help him against you
later brah huh well here's some more
this movie is just downright exhausting
movie tells viewers what it needs to do
in order to enjoy it
Calypso I release you from your human
bonds he didn't say it Roy
sure let's stall this movie even further
hell Barbosa himself said you had to say
it to her as if to a lover but then he
fucks it up five seconds later human
bonds why is this guy able to say the
words and it works doesn't it need to be
a pirate Lord hasn't everything relied
on pirate Lord Boult so far movie steals
the 50-foot woman from a movie I can't
think of right now but it was this movie
about the attack of the 50-foot woman
when a huge woman explodes into millions
of crabs that's probably a sign the
infection has gone too far
you would listen to me rousing speech
time hey one thing they forgot to do
with this movie is give us a reason to
care let's st. William Wallace talking
about getting their freedom and this is
a bunch of lawless pirates and for the
life of me I can't figure out how the
world is a better place if any of them
survive oh I guess I spoke too soon so
this is all about their freedom to loot
and plunder are pirates in these movies
anymore just because the East India
Company is evil doesn't make these
assholes Robin Hood
she in the sky now did she not just turn
into a billion or so crabs and dive into
the sea what was the point of that argh
it is perhaps fitting that one of the
final battles will take place in an
abyss of rapidly rotating water because
it simulates the effect of being in a
toilet how this is the vaunted Black
Pearl you betrayed Jack for in order to
go after your father remember ship
that's faster than the Dutchman as I
recall well I'll throw in jizz later H
Jack Sparrow once again dr. houses his
way into a solution finds this thing
even in the cell if there were no fish
people if he no need to go up to chase
one of these films think we still like
these to asshats
their act worth in two movies ago once
again an unstoppable force like the
Flying Dutchmen which we've seen blowing
up entire waves of pirate ships in
seconds suddenly starts getting its ass
kicked by the Black Pearl
because heroes so can these guys pay off
for Christ's sake and then I skipped and
they just got to the kiss I don't know
you guys finding this wedding during a
sea battle thing funny I think much like
the Captain Jack back in the prison cell
I lost my brain somewhere also these two
do everything without talking it out
they fought and did a whole movies worth
of silent treatment without talking it
out then they just got back together
again without talking that out I mean I
might have to add ten cents for this by
the way does Davy Jones have any reason
to fear Jack sword during this battle we
already had the pretty good joke where
Norrington tried to stab him the Jones
looked at him like he was stupid so why
doesn't he just bum-rush jack and take
the test also this is one of these
fights where it feels like if the Black
Pearl is winning then the whole battle
is won somehow despite the East India
Company having a billion ships elsewhere
in these waters but don't forget about
that lopsided affair as long as the
Black Pearl wins I mean do our comic
relief heroes know exactly where to
shoot this monkey holy Sh they know
exactly where to shoot this monkey it's
official
the first pirates movie was good on
accident since it's clear by this third
movie the creator's have no idea what
made the first one popular Pirates of
the Caribbean at World's End should have
been called the neverending story it's
amazing how in all this confusing battle
things important to the plot just
happened to be close to the heroes
whenever they need them yeah oh now you
remember this is your son nice timing
dickwad at this point we're pretty much
aware that Jack Sparrow can do anything
he wants with a boat sail ropes it's hit
critical mass in this movie and holy SH
is that a parachute
yeah no but what have they been doing
this whole time have they sat back and
watch the Dutchman and the Pearl Duke it
out while drinking tea or something so
the endeavor has cannons on both sides
aren't they not going to get anybody in
position to fire them they're just going
to allow this to happen one ship goes
down and the whole Armada gives up woo
on the wheel then that's the time this
ship had no one at the wheel until this
moment it's one of those ship jobs that
isn't really necessary which kind of
makes will a dick forgiving that
worthless needless job to his own father
once is questioned now hahaha that's
really funny jack but this time there
isn't a cracking around and that's funky
or Knightly you just lost cool points
bro it's at moments like these that I
started thinking wait a minute
all calypso did was create an abyss and
make it rain for a while that's it
she was completely worthless to this
story despite her overall importance to
the story god that was freakin awful
this movie never ends oh it ended
splendid
holy shit didn't end it's even more
movie you can't be around for all the
massive amounts of fun we're going to do
that will likely result in one of your
siblings
this truly is a godforsaken place
[Music]
[Applause]
the skipper has yet to put a single crab
on board the only thing he's captured
another shellacking of dangerous ice
[Music]
you are kept in now under captain now
come play with us daddy
crunchyroll we have it for you no we're
not talking about delicious sushi we're
talking about the anime man crunchyroll
is an anime streaming service that
offers the largest most diverse
collection of anime series that you can
watch in HD with no ads and if your ol
gets you new shows that soon as one
arrow after the air in Japan with
subtitles safe to say that's faster than
you could pirated the best part you can
enjoy it all free for 30 days when you
go to crunchyroll.com slash cinemasins
yes that's a month of free anime bliss
brought to you by anime lovers all you
have to do is click the link in the
description to get started